[Music]
even the best actors have their
melodramatic moments but every once in a
while performances go from a little
over-the-top to insane
maybe these performances are so
over-the-top they circle back around to
brilliant or maybe they're just
embarrassing either way these clips
offer examples of overacting at its
finest John Alderton in Zardoz
everything about 1974 Zardoz is weird
it features Sean Connery with a long
braid and rocking the borat swimsuit
look for most of the film it's a bizarro
trippy movie about a god-like creature
called Saros who talks through a giant
stone head a group of immortals who
don't believe in sex or sleep and
Connery running around with his copious
body hair on display but Connery doesn't
earn the scene chewing crown that honor
goes to John Alderton playing in a
mortal named friend
[Music]
superficial and that's just a taste if
this scene seems confusing don't worry
it doesn't make any more sense in the
context of the film either oh well I
will not bought a second level with you
but you have to applaud alderson for
making the most of his odd moment in
this terribly strange film Nicolas Cage
and vampires kiss you can't talk about
overacting without talking about Nicolas
Cage and Tara plays kiss is one of his
early moments of over-the-top glory long
before his Wickham and remake found him
screaming about bees and punching a
woman while wearing a bear sir he
released what might actually be the
craziest movie of his career 1988
vampire's kiss does Cage as an ad exec
who gets bitten and thinks he's turning
into a vampire and apparently vampires
are a hundred percent insane because
that's how Cage plays his metamorphosis
I didn't respond anything that was not
worked I'm sure oh to be a fly on the
wall as this scene was filmed
if the crew wasn't desperate ly holding
back laughter there must have been
looking for the exits John Travolta in
Battlefield Earth John Travolta wanted
to bring the central mythology of
Scientology to life with Battlefield
Earth instead he created one of the
worst movies of all time and gave a
completely bizarre performance in the
bargain Battlefield Earth is about a
terrible race of dreadlocked aliens who
have enslaved humanity Travolta's stars
as the main bag octo Travolta decided
tow was a guy who loved a good law
doling out his version of an evil
chuckle in almost every scene I do what
I can
[Laughter]
it's a joke if the goal was to make
these gross aliens as unappealing as
possible then Travolta actually did a
perfect job a job we never want to watch
again Michael Sheen in Twilight Breaking
Dawn Part 2 Michael Sheen is a wonderful
actor
he's turned in brilliant performances on
TVs masters of sex and on the big screen
in frost/nixon among many other notable
roles but when it came to Twilight
Breaking Dawn Part 2 he went a little
crazy as the evil ro in fact in a series
filled with unintentionally funny
moments Sheen's bizarre giggle might
stand out as the most memorable
it's funny every time gene actually
offered an explanation of his big moment
to MTV saying that his character has
been alive for centuries and centuries
and he's probably incredibly bored and
gets hysterical when something actually
unexpected happens it really does make
perfect sense when you think about it
which means she managed to turn an
over-the-top moment into a secretly
brilliant acting choice Bravo
Ellen McAvoy in Maximum Overdrive all
the Stephen King decided he wanted to
give moviemaking a try so he adapted his
short story trucks into 1986's Maximum
Overdrive
the good things about the self a full
score by ac/dc the bad things everything
else a story about machines coming to
life and trying to kill all humans
manages to make even less sense than you
think
this was Kings first time directing a
film and he later admitted that one
major issue with the movie was that his
co-director was cocaine despite all the
problems the film has one incredible
highlight the waitress actress Ellen
maca doc makes the most of her limited
screen time if you're going to have a
small part in a crappy film at least
make it memorable Brian Blessed in Flash
Gordon 1980 space opera Flash Gordon
sure had an interesting cast Brian
Blessed an acclaimed British
Shakespearean actor with a big voice and
personality and Max von Sydow a frequent
collaborator within Marburg man who's
considered one of Sweden's greatest
actors played second fiddle to Sam Jay
Jones a former contestant on the dating
game watching Flash Gordon get the sense
that blessed's knew he wasn't winning
any Oscars to the film so he just had as
much fun as humanly possible playing a
winged man who flies around and leather
briefs and a breastplate both Queen play
from the soundtrack why not go over the
top right Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
kenneth branagh in wild wild west in yet
another example of Shakespearean acting
trying to bring a bit of theatrical
Flair to a role in a very silly
blockbuster Kenneth Branagh played the
villainous dr. Lovelace in 1999's Wild
Wild West and infamous loft that snapped
Will Smith's in remarkable 90 streak the
film is suspiciously devoid of humor for
an action thriller slash sci-fi comedy
hybrid among all the fouls jokes we had
the spectacle of Branagh whose betrayal
of Lovelace is so consistently
over-the-top wildly veering from
dramatic to simply insane he's at least
always interesting to watch yes me dear
friend alive and kicking well I am
anyway
Mikasa I Tsukasa - I boo laughs ah party
big yeah Brennan knows that a villain
who winds up in a giant steampunk spider
is not a man for subtlety thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]